I think it was just like after I had
done the first project and I saw the
results of it I wasn't showing anyone it
was just for myself like it was like a
high and I was like I want to keep
figuring this out as I go
[Music]
in 2017 a 23 year old designer in Boston
had an idea Nicole McLaughlin had taken
an entry-level design job at Reebok but
exposure to the waste inherent in the
manufacturing of apparel inspired her to
embark on a series of art projects in
her off hours
she crafted clever one-of-one Footwear
out of found objects like tennis balls
and badminton paraphernalia
her work soon gained a cult following
and as her audience exploded on social
media she started her own company
centered on Art and upcycling teaching
workshops and partnering with blue chip
brands on a variety of environmentally
conscious design forward projects
including collaborations with Reebok and
vans
and it all started with one idea
how does your parents professional life
inform your career Ambitions my parents
are both pretty creative people so I
feel like I was always around it my
whole life my dad was a carpenter and
then he ended up becoming a mall manager
so he was sort of around fashion and
then my mom has always been an interior
designer for commercial spaces so from
like my earliest memories there was
always carpet samples and like chairs in
the back seat of the car and there was
always something creative happening in
my house like they were very crafty and
also really good at working with what
they had so I feel like that definitely
has influenced a lot of the decisions
that I make as a designer when would you
say that you sort of fell in love with
graphic design I got a Macbook when I
was in high school and I got a cracked
version of Illustrator and Photoshop and
that's really when I started doing
editing and doing some stuff on
illustrator but I think once I got to
college that's really when I started to
learn more about graphic design and that
I realized also that it could be done
for clothing too
who were the designers or what were the
sort of brands or products that were
most influential in you in that High
School period my fashion sense was
pretty interesting I was more into like
skateboarding and snowboarding so I wore
a lot of Vans and I loved Burton and
then also during High School I was
really into sign language so I had a
deaf relationship when I was in high
school and I spent a lot of time on
YouTube like watching videos of people
signing and so YouTube was really
helpful I wasn't like the best student
so I think I learned a lot from other
people or watching other people do stuff
and that definitely still applies today
I get creative blocks a lot and I find
that the best way to get through it is
to just continue to create I find that
sometimes it's helpful if I paint
something or I take photos you know
taking a step back and doing something
else that's creative
[Music]
what do you feel like was like the most
important things that you learned in
college
time to grow and to meet people and try
different things and I landed in digital
media and it was a pretty broad major
that allowed you to just kind of explore
all different forms of doing photography
doing videography sound recording and I
really appreciated that time and there
was also a lot of equipment that I could
use for not for free but essentially to
me for free I was like oh I can use all
this equipment and I really took
advantage of that and that's how I
learned all the programs and things I
needed for my time at Reebok did you
have any sort of sense of what you
wanted to do as a career at that point I
always was like tinkering and using my
hands to make stuff but I never would
have thought that what I do now is even
a possibility like I knew the fashion
industry existed and I I liked fashion
but I didn't really understand that as
like a career choice especially with
Footwear and Graphics being applied to
garments or to Footwear so I found this
internship working for Reebok and I just
applied to it I had no idea like I
thought I'd be doing graphics for social
media or Graphics that were meant for
advertisements and then once I got there
I learned that I was doing graphics for
clothing and that was like the craziest
experience to learn how the fashion
industry works and understand how
clothes are made once I learned all
those things it was like this is
definitely more of the direction that I
want to go in
when you applied for the internship at
Reebok was this a paid internship it was
paid which was great and I got I moved
to Boston so that was a really big
change from college to then moving to a
new city it was all really exciting but
really nerve-wracking and I knew it was
kind of my chance to prove myself and
like get into the industry so I didn't
waste a second of it and I worked really
hard that whole year and what what kinds
of stuff did they have you making I was
doing graphics for running that was what
I was placed on so I was doing repeat
patterns for tights for shoes and then I
got put on this project which at the
time I didn't even realize like how much
this would impact me but it Reebok
started doing collaborations
um with some fashion brands and vet mall
at the time was just kind of taking off
and they did a collab with Reebok on an
insta pump Fury so I had to take this
shoe that demna essentially scribbled
all over had to take it part and
recreate it all in Photoshop to be able
to make it Factory ready and so that
they could make it in mass production
and it took me weeks and weeks and weeks
and I was like sleeping at the office
and stuff and yeah it's kind of where it
all started
I like the idea of luck and I think a
lot of the people in this industry say
that luck is somehow a factor in their
success whether it's being at the right
place at the right time or discovering
something at that moment but there's
also just a layer of being perceptive to
things and pushing yourself to do the
best you can do
one transition from this sort of
one-year internship program to becoming
a full-time employee there as are crazy
because they put us all against each
other
their friends that you set
Nick there's like one job so you all
have to fight for it now and I think my
competitive Spirit really came out and I
was like I'm gonna get this job because
I'm not moving back home with my parents
in New Jersey so I used that experience
and I I built my portfolio and I was
thankful I got the job and so I was
hired full time doing graphics for
Reebok Classics which was where I wanted
to be because it was all the really cool
exciting products that had the
collaborations but also referenced all
the archive stuff and Reebok has an
amazing history it was really cool to
have that experience I got to do some
cool stuff I got to do like throwback
Allen Iverson jerseys and make all the
cool graphics and stuff for inline
apparel
foreign
at what point in this journey did you
start working on your own personal art
projects so
working at Reebok a couple of years
before I started doing my personal
projects I started to realize how much
waste there was coming out of the
industry I would be sitting at my desk
and there would be boxes of samples just
surrounding me and it's a half a pair
that's the wrong color the wrong
material so it kind of is just destined
to be trashed and thrown out and so I
started to rummage and pick through
these things that they were just going
to get rid of and taking them home with
me like not really knowing what I was
going to do but I was like I could maybe
try to find a way to use this I first
started hot gluing everything and then
from there I was like What if I hand sew
it and then I got better at every
project
when I say where my ideas come from it
sounds a little bit corny but they
really do come from everywhere I think a
lot of the time material is used only
for its intended purpose so I like to
try to change that
[Music]
you're a young person in a new city I
imagine you are pursuing an active
social life and you have like other
things going on and you're also working
your ass off at your job where's the
motivation coming from to be like Oh I'm
gonna spend like 12 hours at home
tinkering with this thing or teaching
myself to sew without
a concrete end in mind I look back at
that time and I
I think it was just like after I had
done the first project and I saw the
results of it I wasn't showing anyone it
was just for myself it made me feel
really good and inspired and I was like
I want to keep like it was like a high
and I was like I want to keep figuring
this out like what if I get better and
like what if I just keep taking new
materials and and figuring this out as I
go
on the weekends I would go out and try
to rummage through thrift stores and my
house and everywhere Reebok had an
office in Canton that they closed and I
would go back there and
try to find materials and take it home
with me the energy was just so high at
the time too
how long did it take from sort of
starting to like acquire these skills to
getting to a place where you're even
showing friends I'd say a year probably
I was making this stuff just in my
bedroom not showing anybody and then I
would show like some friends and then I
would be working on stuff at my desk
occasionally because it was like
starting to take over my life where it
was like the only thing I was thinking
of and then I started posting it on
social
and one of like my first ones that I
felt good about that I posted it someone
was like oh like was this an actual shoe
and I was like oh wow that's like such a
crazy compliment because I went from hot
gluing something to making something
that looked like it could actually have
been made and so from then I was just
like oh I can just you know keep sharing
this and show the progress of me making
stuff and then a couple months after
that I made a series where I did a shoe
out of a tennis ball a shoe out of a
volleyball and a shoe out of a soccer
ball and that's when I started to like
pick up traction on like social and
followers and it was really scary
honestly I was not prepared for it and I
didn't realize how fast that could
happen
it was exciting but also I was like
do I have what it takes to continue
doing this and like am I doing it for me
or am I doing it for them now this was
always a creative side project and I
never wanted to lose that it was a
pretty fast switch like once all that
traction started I was like oh wow I
have to be taking this serious
after getting her first taste of public
success Nicole continued to expand on
her trade crap including honing her
skills at the legendary Adidas creators
Farm as her unique passion projects
continue to attract attention she
recognized an opportunity to step out on
her own and found a company that could
Encompass the breadth of her upcycling
ambition from collabs to Consulting to
education
[Music]
during your time at Reebok you ended up
going to work at the farm in Adidas the
parent company of Reebok
um work with Mark Dolce who's you know
sort of a design God what was that
experience like and how was it different
than the experience within Reebok the
farm was this Disneyland for designers
basically it was an office where people
could come and they had an unlimited
resource of materials and a Makerspace
and knowledgeable people who worked in
there the designers from Adidas would
come and they would do a three-month
rotation and I was the first Reebok
designer that got offered the
opportunity to do the rotation at the
farm so I was really really excited for
that and at the time I had just really
started you know doing my personal
projects
I was in such a creative space filled
with so many creative people that were
almost on this like sabbatical thing so
yeah are you working on like projects
that are meant to come to fruition or is
it more sort of like a r d like
experimental thing a bit of both but
definitely more with the intention of
like creating projects yeah that would
come out in maybe three or four years
time it was pretty Advanced like
timeline and so yeah that was just like
a knowledge explosion during that time
and sewing that that was like where I
really got my skill set
[Music]
my biggest Advantage as a Creator is to
be able to show what goes on in my mind
physically I think it's a visual
representation of my thoughts
as you start to have these viral moments
is this something that is talked about
at Reebok with your manager with your
team and
the
people I worked with had no idea that
this was happening and then there was
one time and this was the moment that I
knew it was time to quit
um I was in a meeting and this outside
marketing agency came in to do like a
presentation to Reebok and they put me
in a deck and were like oh you should
collaborate with this girl and I was
sitting in the meeting and all my
co-workers like turned and looked at me
and I was like okay I guess I have to I
gotta do something about that I never
thought that I would do freelance I
never thought I would own a business I
didn't understand anything about it I
was kind of scared actually to even
consider that because in my head I was
like I've made it like I have a cup like
a corporate job that has like a name and
you know I've worked really hard to get
here but I knew that I wasn't I'm not
always going to have you know the most
popular social media I'm not always
going to be the most relevant and I'm
totally fine with that but the moments
that you do have it it's kind of like a
make or break thing where it's like like
if you want to use this moment use it
and capitalize on it and so I was like
let's do it
making things the way that you do and
they're all you know sort of one-on-ones
or at least that in that moment it was
all one of ones the obvious path towards
monetizing that would be to go and sell
them and figure out whether you know
it's on some sort of marketplace or
whatever you were very pointed in not
wanting to sell these pieces what was
the sort of motivation philosophically
to not have any sort of commercial
element with the personal projects first
of all it's really challenging to make
these pieces sometimes and like at scale
if I was to sit there and make even only
10 or 20 versions of this first of all
it's never going to look exactly the
same every time something bad it's going
to feel different and a lot of the time
the material I use there is only one I
could find of it and sometimes I'm using
mismatched souls or you know different
parts of things and it's hard to
duplicate what I do
something that I always realized as a
consumer myself like you see stuff
online and like immediate you're like oh
I like that I want to buy it and I don't
feel like everything needs to be
purchased and so a lot of the pieces
that I have that are a bit like crazier
Wilder like you wouldn't have the same
experience even if you did own it like I
think it's something about what you get
when you see it you have it you feel it
and then you know you kind of keep
moving on at your day you'll come back
and look at it or reference it or
however but you don't need to own it to
have an experience with it
how you know as you are thinking I'm
going to quit my job and pursue running
my own you know myself as a business
kind of how were you thinking about
monetizing it and making it work
financially it started actually with the
workshops so that was my first
opportunity as a freelancer was like oh
well why don't you teach people how to
sew like if that's what you know how to
do and again like I had just started
this like I was not an expert but I was
like I can teach people like if I could
figure this out like people can do this
I had that as an opportunity and then my
first like bigger brand project was with
a extension of Foot Locker it was called
greenhouse and they offered me a project
to do a collaboration with Crocs and so
I was like okay like I didn't know what
that really meant and I was like can
this be scaled in a way that still feels
like me that still has a part of my
identity in the ethos of upcycling
knowing that it's still it's going to be
created new how can I make this me and
so that's sort of where it started and I
saw a business opportunity and then I
started to realize I can work with these
companies from the inside out so my
experience from Reebok really can apply
here where it's like these brands have
all this stuff and I know it because
I've seen it how can we find a way to
use it can we bring this back into
production can we do workshops you know
there's to me it was dollar signs
because it's material that they're ready
to throw away and I was like if I can
make something cool out of it like I'll
take it and I'll I'll use it and then
they're like oh how can we get get
involved in it
My ultimate creative goal is to make
upcycling a more popular thing to be
able to show the potential of waste and
to show that the fashion industry as a
whole can do a lot better
what was the process for putting
together kind of the itinerary or the
curriculum for the Workshops the
workshops have always been more or how
can someone leave with a skill that they
didn't have when they came and I always
thought that sewing was really scary and
I like sometimes I still think sewing's
kind of scary and if you like been in
front of a sewing machine before it's
like there's a lot of power that you
hold in your hands and you're like I
don't really know what I'm doing I want
them to leave with the finished product
but if anything if they could leave with
some type of skill set even if it is
hand sewing just to be able to
understand how something is made I think
is important that can leave with them
being able to repair something or be
able to hem a pair of pants that they've
thrifted if we work with a brand it's a
sponsored moment where they'll provide a
box of shoe samples or dead stock Fabric
or clothes that are donated back to them
and we'll use that and it's cool because
they get to have the discovery element
of taking something and flipping it
inside out finding Pockets finding
pullers and using everything that you
can because it's valuable
you left Reebok in 2019 and started this
business sort of in Earnest going right
into the pandemic how did that affect
kind of getting things off the ground
that was really scary I think
that was like the craziest time to
decide to go freelance I was really
nervous to make that jump and then once
that happened too I was like what am I
gonna do and also because my well of
materials just kind of it dried up
because I didn't have Reebok materials
and all the thrift stores and things
that I was going to to get materials I
didn't have during covet either so it
really forced me to dig super deep and I
was just using literally everything in
my house and I was getting really
creative with the stuff that I had and
this is also around the time that I
started taking apart all the projects
that I was making so I was like I'll
make it I'll take a picture of it I'll
take it apart and then I can use that
material again for another project so a
lot of the stuff that I've made like
you've probably seen it and you're like
oh that's actually that's the same Soul
like that's the same fleece material
that's been used you know at this point
dozens of times so I think it's a really
good good thing to happen
um
and also started to realize I needed to
create boundaries between me and my work
too I think as a freelancer you start to
realize like you you run a business that
becomes your whole entire life and
you're never able to turn it off
I was experiencing a lot of burnout then
I was like if I don't set these healthy
boundaries now will I ever that was also
a time of reflection for me to be able
to do that
striking out on her own just as the
pandemic began would force Nicole to
expand her DIY toolkit even further
her technical skills and philosophy
regarding the creative process would
provide a broad foundation for Success
culminating with a satisfying full
circle moment
[Music]
I think it's interesting just hearing
the language used that you you frame it
as going freelance as opposed to like
launching a brand or starting a company
do you still feel like
you are like a freelance designer or do
you feel like you are you know the
captain of this Enterprise
I've legitimized the operation so I I
should have I should graduate from the
the term freelancer but for some reason
in my head I'm mentally kind of still
there I don't feel big enough I guess to
be a brand but at this point like I am
creating stuff that people are wearing
and buying so in a way like that's sort
of how it is and I I am an LLC and I pay
people and so it is a bigger ship than
I'm like still thinking it's a sailboat
I guess and it's actually like a ship
but I like mentally kind of keeping it
still as like my personal project I
don't want to lose that I'm like scared
that I'm gonna lose that because that's
why I love it so much and it's mine and
I care about it and I don't want it to
become so big that it's like a machine
how would you describe your brand
I have a couple different arms of it
where my personal work is still the
Forefront that's where I get my ideas I
still love dedicating my time to making
things and trying things out and knowing
that it's probably not going to work and
then I have these brand projects where
it's a collaboration and it's Footwear
it's a parallel they come to me they
have an idea for a model of a shoe and
I'm like okay well what material do you
have that's potentially destined for the
trash like can we use that can we do a
super small run and we can do a really
like small customizable version of it
and make it a little bit crazier I think
it's more about still upcycling is at
the Forefront of everything and making
responsible design choices when it comes
to sourcing materials but Whimsy and fun
is also a big part of my brand and my
identity is playfulness and putting
pockets on things that don't maybe
necessarily need a pocket but I think it
does
what are the qualities about yourself
that you hold on to the most tightly my
childhood sense of wonder I think that's
always been a huge part of my work and
just my life I love to have fun and I
don't always love to take things too
seriously especially being in an
industry that is pretty serious at times
I think it's always fun to approach it
with a light-heartedness and that's
what's kind of kept me going
a lot of the work you do is with Brands
which means that you have to sort of
interface with people there and they
have their own agenda and their
expectations that always the outset of
these relationships are aligned at least
on paper but then as it plays out
sometimes there's it reveals uh
misalignment yeah I've definitely
experienced that I'd say the majority of
the time the brands that I work with
kind of know what they're signing up for
and I'm not I'm not a safe designer in
any aspect of like the process I like to
sort of push my limits and also the
company that I'm working with limits on
what they've made in the past and what
we can create together that feels
authentic to both of us but I think
having the design integrity and also
identity for me is really important to
keep secure Brands will come to me now
for advice which I love and they're like
we don't know what to do with all this
stuff we have a box that's sitting in
the warehouse it's costing us more money
to have it in the warehouse than it
would be to get rid of it let's call
Nicole like what kind of things would
that be if it's crazy like things that
don't even make it onto the floor at a
store because the tag on the clothes
like maybe created a small hole in it
even if like there was a couple pieces
like that they'll get sent back so like
it's not even noticeable to a consumer
or if a roll of fabric has like one
water marker some type of like ink mark
on one part of the Roll the whole thing
will get scrapped just like wear testing
they could be halfway through like
producing a shoe and then something
fails on it and they're like actually
nope we gotta take everything off the
factory line and figure this out
that's a big part of what I've been
doing now I love that type of work and a
lot of the time the brand partnership
start is like a social media ask and
then have turned into this whole like
I'm like let me take a look at your
factory and your business and let's see
what we can do here and definitely
overstepping boundaries as much as I
possibly can how do you think about the
content that you're making and you know
the upside of social media is the
interconnectedness and the fact that we
can reach so many people the downside is
that yes you know that you're in a
feedback loop even if you're trying to
fight B in that feedback loop I think at
some point I had to tune it out it's
nice to be able to create a place for
conversation and I like that and I
always I leave comments are always on
because I want people to have a dialogue
but at the same time you shouldn't let
what people say always influence the
decisions that you're making and over
time I was like you know what people are
going to have their opinions whether
they like it or not they're thinking
about it they're commenting on it and I
think the ultimate like message that I'm
trying to achieve is is getting people's
perception around waste and you know the
the bad side of the fashion industry I
want people to change their minds about
this stuff and so as long as they're
interacting with it some way it's
helpful I think
[Music]
I think to be able to tell a good idea
from a bad idea you have to do both and
I definitely have experienced a lot of
bad ideas and they somehow always lead
me in the right direction so I just kind
of have to let it happen
[Music]
has there ever been a project that
you've made and felt so good about and
confident in and then posted it and had
it not connect a while ago I had all
this material from puma and it was
samples that were made for the Olympics
and it was like track spikes and balls
and gloves and all these like things
that were meant to be for sport and I it
was a sculptural piece and it wasn't
really meant to be wearable but it was
meant to be more for display my idea was
to make like art like a series of armor
out of all these like track spikes on
like the arms and like I think that was
definitely like one of those times where
I was like oh wow okay like conceptual
doesn't always hit with the audience but
to me it really pushed my design skills
and also I got a lot of projects out of
it I had so many people reference like
brands that came to me after that
referenced that that image and they're
like this was like a sculpture like we
want something like this and I ended up
doing
um a sculpture for the Super Bowl last
year for Nike because of that project
and it was just kind of crazy that that
happened so I always save like people
that aren't really sure about if they
should put something or if they think
it's too out there like not their normal
style like go for it anyway because like
who cares about metrics at the end of
the day if it's gonna get you work and
it's gonna get you you know the right
people's attention you never know so it
worked out
obviously as the business has grown and
the opportunities have grown you don't
physically make every single thing with
your hands anymore you know have people
that you work with how has it been to
sort of detach yourself from the
physicality of that part of the creation
it's challenging I never thought that I
would give that part of it up but at
some point I had to to be able to be a
business person and be able to go and
take meetings and go places and and keep
things running because it used to be if
I had to travel somewhere everything
stopped and I had to I was sewing in
hotel rooms and like it it wasn't
working for me so I found people that I
really trust and that understand me and
my vision but also they have their own
Vision as well and how we can work
together and I think I still have a hand
in in everything whether that's the
concept is usually coming that's me
usually and the physical making part of
it could be passed off to other people
but it's it's ours like it still feels
like a part of me because it came from
my brain and you know just because I
didn't sit there and physically sew the
whole thing but that was a a big Letting
Go moment and I think a lot of people
experience that as a you know creative
but in in any business sense where it's
like you were the one doing every job
and at some points like you can't
physically do everything so you're gonna
have to be able to delegate and I've
gotten better at it but it's always
something that I'm working on
the most important idea that I've ever
had is letting go I think for me my
projects are meant to live in a moment
of time and and I never stay stuck on
one thing
[Music]
you have
established yourself very prominently in
the Footwear industry
without necessarily coming into it as a
sneaker head or
real like sneaker Enthusiast what would
you say is your sort of relationship to
sneakers at this point I do love
sneakers and I yeah I didn't grow up a
sneaker head per se I mean I always
thought about my Footwear choices but it
was always more from a utility
standpoint and it's still a lot of the
time is what has brought me closer to
them is the history of shoes and how
inspiring that is to me Reebok's first
running shoe ever was like the first
running shoe and was a literal like
nails as track spikes if you even think
about like the first like women's
athletic shoe was came out in the 80s
like designed specifically for women and
like that's not that long ago you know
it's like it's pretty crazy to realize
like that we're in this moment so I
think that's what really gets me excited
about Footwear I love being able to
contribute to that in some way and yeah
just seeing brands that are coming up
with really Innovative things and yeah I
just I love that part of it you are
wearing a collaboration that you've
recently released with Reebok with your
name on it this was a huge full circle
moment for me from being a literal
intern at the branch of having a shoe I
just never would have thought in my
wildest dreams the scared intern that
was afraid of everything uh and to now
they came to me with the model and it
was a women's specific model it's called
The Geo mid and I really loved it I just
thought it was customizable there was a
good canvas for me to work off of and it
reminded me of this shoe from the 90s
called the Aetna mid and it's funny
because that's really where I pulled a
lot of the inspiration from and I got to
utilize my knowledge of the Reebok
archive to be able to design my shoe and
also utilize my knowledge of the company
as a whole like the development team and
the marketing team who I had worked with
in the past so it was like we don't need
to be introduced because I know you
already and so it just worked really
well having that experience and being
able to kind of put myself to the test
but yeah my parents could not believe
that I had my name on a shoe that was a
really cool moment they were like you
your name is on there like that's do
they have beers they do my mom has a
parent she's been sporting it yep
what else is on the bucket list I
definitely want to get more into
homewares and furniture that was
something that I've I've dabbled in the
past couple years an ultimate dream of
mine would be to have a kids like a
children's museum and have it be more of
like a museum of science or like an
experimental type of place where people
like can come and touch and create and
make things so like almost like my
workshops but in a larger sense and kid
friendly
and also I have some really crazy
projects coming up that I'm excited
about and it is really it wasn't like
dipping a toe within the Footwear
industry I'm like fully submerging
myself in it so I'm really excited to
see how it goes and also how every
project we can do can be closer to being
a fully upcycled shoe that's really the
goal that's honestly like within a
five-year plan is to work with a brand
to do an entirely upcycled shoe at scale
like not just 100 pairs like a thousand
or a couple thousand plus pairs of shoes
[Music]
thank you